hey you - tick-tock tick-tock where the
[ __ ] is my diamond play button it's been
84 years yeah that's why you - I said it
you think I'm scared like all these
other [ __ ] ass youtubers like
markiplier jacksepticeye or cinnamon
toes can hunt it wah
oh yeah it's your boy your boy here
it's your boy welcome to the rose big
[ __ ]
prepare to get it filled what's the word
infiltrate prepared to get annihilated
hey youtube what a great streaming
service you got there with YouTube red
to bad Netflix is already been a thing
oh please still fun YouTube scare
PewDiePie YouTube red but you ate [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's right you eat [ __ ] though
meat and how about that YouTube
streaming service good thing twitch
isn't already a thing oh oh god the
truth you speak the truth
that's Jason true oh Jesus ah hello
hello so and YouTube that comment system
is [ __ ] awesome
just kidding it's not all the power of
huge compelling you the power is gonna
bounce you are you compare oh are you
the spirit hi is it hot in here or is
your ass just getting roasted rubber
ducks [ __ ] drove or duck wait
hey YouTube Google+ is a great idea too
bad Facebook is an old radio thing Oh
leave it like hey YouTube I'm proud of
you you made so much money throughout
the year
oh wait you didn't make [ __ ] oh how
might you take more than 45% of our
income wait what yeah you take four to
five percent 45 percent 25 percent
youtube gaming more like youtube blaming
ha ha
you missed on purpose right yes your
bread
more like here you your pawn em you red
tube hey youtube your search algorithm
is so corrupt it makes body more Putin
look like Jesus oh Jesus do we need an
LEP what do I need another clip who the
[ __ ] is that
I think it's me I'll check it out